Hey everyone Diavolo here and I think that to
start off this massive video going over every
single cursed technique inside of the verse, that
we firstly delve into the teachers of each school
and their respective techniques, then work our
way though the rest from there. Ofcourse not
every person will be mentioned because sometimes
2 people might have the same technique and some
sorcerers dont even have an innate or inherited
technique. Also for you disgusting anime only’s,
this will include a bunch of stuff
from the manga. So you’ve been warned.
Satoru Gojo - Getting into it though and being
one of the strongest people inside of the verse,
rip the strongest, Jujutsu tech’s first
year teacher, Satoru Gojo is equipped with
a plethora of different abilities that weve
seen being used in variety of different ways.
(Six Eyes) Firstly, putting him
already a mile above the rest,
Gojo born with these bad boys. A Six Eyes
bearer has immense perception and unrivaled
visual prowess far beyond that of any other
sorcerer. Their eyesight is comparable to
high-definition infrared camera and they can
easily see things from several kilometers away.
At all times the Six Eyes are constantly
active, kinda like a passive trait your
unable to deactivate. Weirdly and im assuming
because they’re a physical body part the person
was born with, but they dont seem to actually
take up any cursed energy itself. More just
placing a physical burden on the user if the
eyes are uncovered for an extended period
of time. The Six Eye’s are without issue,
able to observe the flow of cursed energy,
gifting their user with the added ability to read
an individual's cursed technique and determine
its function. They can even differentiate
between different types of cursed energy,
which in turn allows the user to
figure out who they might be facing.
The Six Eyes allow for the extremely
precise manipulation of cursed energy,
down to an atomic level. This not only allows
the bearer to operate the Limitless through
the complex control of cursed energy but enables
them to process it with great efficiency as well.
Speaking of limitless, next up.
(Limitless) At the base level and just like
the eyes themselves, Limitless is an innate
technique which is passed down inside of the Gojo
Family. This technique grants its users an almost
absolute control over an un-tangible space through
CE manipulation. In turn, anything that approaches
the infinity slows down and never reaches the
user. This is because the technique takes the
finite amount of space between the two subjects
and divides it an infinite amount of times.
In math's, no matter how many times you divide
a number, it will never reach zero. Instead,
you're left with incredibly tiny
fractional parts that are almost
impossible to measure with our basic human
eyes. Now, imagine if we could bring this
mathematical concept to life and thats how we
get the insanely broken ability of Limitless.
Due to just how brilliant and
in-depth of a technique that it is,
Limitless has three standard and one
"non-standard" techniques beyond this.
(Cursed Technique Lapse or Blue) The first of
these is, Cursed Technique Lapse or Blue. This
remarkable technique not only cranks up the
cursed energy output to unprecedented levels
but also generates the power to attract. This
is achieved by amplifying the Limitless and
bringing the conceptual impossibility of
negative distance into reality. This forces
the surrounding space to try and fill in the
gap by pulling violently toward the source
of the previously mentioned impossibility,
creating the magnetic-like effect. Plus I
guess we can chuck in the Maximum Output
version of this technique to just pad
the already ridiculously long video. (Cursed
Technique Maximum Cursed Energy Output Blue)
(Cursed Technique Reversal: Red) The second
of the three, is the reversal of limitless.
So unlike how blue played on the effects of
cursed energy, cursed technique reversal red
is the opposite as it reverses the effect of the
strengthened technique and brings the divergence
of infinity into reality, generating the power
to repel. Gojo is able to achieve his first
use of it in his second battle against Toji
after he was physically pushed to his limits.
As he said after returned, this is achieved by
flowing reverse cursed energy into the power
of the Limitless, creating a repelling effect
thats over 2 times stronger in comparison to blue.
Ofcourse the reason he failed to use Red
initially against that paper bag head dude,
was because Gojo’s application
of RCT wasn't there yet.
(Reverse Curse Technique) While we are here,
mise aswell explain that RCT, or Reverse
Curse Technique, technically isn't a cursed
technique, but a special type of sequence
that takes cursed energy and reverses it into
positive energy. It is a very complex ability
and is mainly used to heal human bodies. Dont
ask me why its not specifically a technique,
I just know Gege Akutami came out and
specifically said it at one point.
As we learnt recently, Reverse Cursed
Technique also allows someone to restore
their exhausted Cursed Technique.
However, it's important to note
that you can't simultaneously recover your
physical body and your Cursed Technique.
Its one or the other... What I find
most messed up, like Gege is crazy,
is that rejuvenating a worn-out Cursed Technique
involves damaging the section of the brain where
these techniques are imprinted and then healing
it using a Reverse Cursed Technique. Bruh.
(Long Distance Teleportation) Another
ability that Gojo is only able to use
due to his Six Eyes is the advanced technique
Long Distance Teleportation. Like the name says,
a Limitless user is able to use spatial
manipulation to teleport long distances,
although the user can only teleport them
self instantly with a hand signal. This
is achieved by compressing the space
between the user's location and their
desired destination. To teleport multiple
people, the limitless user would need to
draw a sorcery circle large enough to hold
the amount of people they want to teleport.
Lastly out of the techniques only a limitless
user can achieve and another advanced one,
we have the Hollow Technique Purple. Like I
mentioned before, Blue and Red make up the
first 2 main abilities found within limitless.
Hollow Purple the third is the fusion of both of
them, a secret ability known to only a few within
the Gojo Family. Who though like straight up,
this has been said so many times, but
we are still yet to even meet someone
other than Gojo from the Gojo clan. Either
way, this ability represents the motion
of blue and reversal of red, a fusion of
convergence and divergence that collides
both infinites to generate an imaginary
mass that destroys anything it touches.
(Black Flash) Well here is a personal favorite
of mine due to how mappa snaps with every
single application of it in the series,
Black Flash. As everyone’s surely heard,
so ill be quick with this one, Black
Flash is a distortion in space that
occurs when cursed energy is applied within
0.000001 seconds of a physical hit. When a
sorcerer is able to achieve this, their
cursed energy flashes the color black,
and the destructive power of their strike is
equal to a normal hit to the power of 2.5.
So whatever that normal hit is, chuck it in a
exponent calculator and you’ll get the answer.
Masamichi Yaga - Masamichi Yaga, the 50 year
old man with a crippling plushy addiction has
one of the strongest and actually feared
over abilities inside of the series.
(Cursed Corpse Manipulation) Unlike Mahito’s
manipulation of corpses, Masamichi doesn't use
people but instead is able to infuse the dolls
he creates with a cursed energy core in order
to bring the inanimate objects to life and control
them with an incantation. He has developed a wide
variety of different cursed corpses including
Panda, Tsukamoto, Cathy and of-course the lil
man himself Takeru. The reasoning I give behind
him being feared over is actually because the
potential threat of a multitude of sentient
cursed corpses nearly lead the higher-ups to
promote Masamichi to special grade and place an
indefinite restriction on him. Since that point,
Masamichi has kept his other creations a
secret within a forest protected by Tengen.
Yoshinobu Gakuganji - Ahh these three
have been fitting to stick together
if ya know what I mean.. Sadly the
guy who dealt the finishing blow,
Yoshinobu Gakuganji had an
even more lethal ability.
(Gakuganji’s Unnamed Technique) Looking like
a Rockstar and using a technique that we dont
know the name of but have an understanding
of how it works. Gakuganji’s technique uses
his body as a form of sound amplification
device, amplifying anything that he plays on
his electric guitar and in turn, it launches
waves of amped up electrical cursed energy.
Utahime Iori - Being an avid lover of beer,
Utahime and her ability’s
effect comes with no surprise.
(Solo forbidden Area) Solo Forbidden Area is an
innate technique that creates a zone around the
sorcerer that temporarily amplifies the cursed
energy of any person within range, including
herself. Solo Forbidden Area is not particularly
suited for combat as it requires preparation time
and is best applied to enhancing allies. I haven't
mentioned this as of yet, probably could have with
Gojo but I rambled on with some of his abilities.
The technique can be elevated into a ritual using
incantations, hand signs, dance, and music. By
including all of these steps, the technique's
effectiveness can be raised to 120%. This however
doesn't just work for Utahime, all sorcerers are
able to elevate their techniques, its more or
less just a time based thing during battle.
Yuji Itadori - So that brings all of
the teachers inside of Jujutsu Kaisen,
both at Kyoto and Jujutsu techs schools
to an end. If I dont mention any specific
characters and their techniques, its
either because we haven't seen them
use one or they share in one with another
character that i've already spoken about.
When it comes to Yuji he also doesn't
have any innate or inherited technique,
however he is equipped with his own unique
effect. Ps Yuji might be like a few chapters
away from learning a cursed technique, so if he
does end up having one itl be awesome to see him
gain something. Like mans used divergent fist for
how long now, and im assuming itl have something
to do with body swapping after seeing that
short section of him practicing with Kusakabe.
When it comes to the big Divergent Fist,
simply, if Yuji strikes with his fist
using a thin layer of cursed energy,
a second wave of cursed energy is unleashed a
few moments afterward, effectively creating two
impacts with one punch. This is as Gojo said
early on in the series, because Yuji is to
physically quick his cursed energy lags and takes
time to catch up, creating that double impact.
Megumi Fushiguro - Second of the series main trio,
Megumi Fushiguro is stocked up with an arsenal
of Shikigami that originate from an inherited
technique passed down inside of the Zenin Clan.
(Ten Shadows Technique) This is of course,
the illustrious 10 shadows technique. This
technique grants the user complete manipulation
of shadows, allowing someone to hide in them or
store objects. It also grants them the
possibility to summon upto 10 different
Shikigami using a specific correlating hand
signal and the shadows as an intermediary
between the shadow and human realms. When
someone inherits the Ten Shadows Technique,
they initially receive two Divine Dogs. From
which other shikigami can be summoned with an
exorcism ritual where the user must defeat
the shikigami in order to make them submit.
Throughout the series we see Big Megumi
throw up his gang signs a multitude of times,
pretty much allowing us to see all 10 of
his chosen Shikigami from the shadow realm.
(Divine Dogs) The first Divine
Dogs are a pair of twin wolves
that can comfortably take out lower grade curses.
(Divine Dog: Totality) After having the
white hound killed by the finger bearer.
Another application of the Ten Shadows Technique
is seen when Megumi uses the liquid like remains
to mix the wolves together, turning them into
one larger and much much stronger Shikigami,
The Divine Dog: Totality. Totality is
strong enough to contend with special
grade cursed spirits, making it one
Megumi's strongest offensive shikigami.
(Nue) Probably my favorite out of his
Shikigami, just due to the fact it can fly,
would have to be Nue. Nue is a winged shikigami
armed with an extremely high top speed and
electrical wings. It can 1 person by carrying
them while flying to increase their mobility,
and can attack with its heavy wings charged
with electricity, shocking anyone it hits
and leaving them temporarily paralyzed. In
addition to basic offensive applications,
Nue's speed and wings can also be used defensively
to shield its user from any potential harm.
(Toad) 3rd of the known Shikigami’s Toad, is a
large frog shikigami that can support its master
using its long tongue. Im assuming you could
ride on it too, or use it like stepping stones
as we saw with Nanami, but its mainly seen using
the tounge. Its tongue can be used to ensnare
its master's target in a tough hold and is strong
enough to throw those same targets around with its
tounge. Its large size also allows it to carried
injured humans in its mouth for protection,
but like I mentioned the biggest upside
to the toad is the tounge and its speed.
(Great Serpent) Next up, big Orochi or the Great
Serpent is a giant snake shikigami that can
quickly attack and ensnare its users target within
a constrictive hold. The snake seems to be more of
a sneak attack like weapon, as the user can use
it to attack from the shadows at a high speed.
The Great Serpent's size allows it to overpower
large curses, possibly even swallow them in one
go and can also be used to keep a target in place
while other shikigami launch combination attacks.
(Max Elephant) So not including Sukuna’s Shikigami
as we’ll get to those later, Megumi’s Max Elephant
is defiantly his most explosive shikigami. As
we’ve all seen, the shikigami is capable of
spewing large, violent torrents of water from
its trunk that are capable of pushing back or
even drowning the intended target. It can also be
used to crush its masters target with its immense
weight, However, the cost of cursed energy to
summon this Shikigami is huge in comparison to
others. This in turn and obviously depending on
the user, will only allow them to summon it once.
(Rabbit Escape) Being a polar opposite to Max
Elephant, Megumi’s 6th Shikigami, Rabbit Escape,
is a massive swarm of rabbit like shikigami
that serve as more of a distraction for the
user than an attack in itself. Upon activating
the technique, dozens, like im unsure if we get
an exact number, but a bunch of rabbits
fill the area to distract the opponent,
allowing the summoner to escape danger or use them
to his advantage and attack the confused opponent.
(Eight Handled Sword Divergent Sila Divine
General Mahoraga) Lastly the big man himself,
Mahoraga who idek if I should include as apart of
the Ten Shadows or talk about more with Sukuna,
but we’ll just do him here. To summon this
being its slightly different. Unlike hand
signs with all others, all you need to do
with Mahoraga is extend both arms forward.
On top of this, an incantation is required
to bring him forth and begin the ritual.
This being though is by far the
most powerful shikigami available
to be summoned by someone with this
the Ten Shadows Techniques. however,
no one in the history of the Zenin Family
has ever been able to force it to submit.
Unlike all other Shikigami, Mahoraga is equipped
with its own kind of techniques. Firstly this dude
is armed with a weapon called the Sword
of Extermination. This blade is attached
to the Shikigami’s forearm and enveloped in
positive cursed energy, making it especially
effective against cursed spirits. Secondly,
the being possesses the ability to adapt to
any and all phenomena. How this works is that
say, if it is injured by a particular attack,
the eight-handled wheel will turn, allowing
it to adapt. This can take up to a few spins
depending on just how in-depth the technique
its trying to adapt is. If after all of the
spins needed to adapt complete, Mahoraga will
counter it. This works offensively as well,
allowing Mahoraga to figure out a way around
the technique so he’s able to deal damage.
Nobara Kugisaki - Third of the series main trio,
Nobara Kugisaki, the country girl actually boasts
large reserves of cursed energy and is an
expert at manipulating it to her will. This
isn't specifically mentioned in the anime
or manga, but in the Fanbook we learn where
Nobara got her ability from. Like Megumi, the
Straw Doll Technique is passed down inside of
the Kugisaki family, with Nobara specifically
inheriting the technique from her grandmother.
(Straw Doll Technique) The Straw Doll Technique
incorporates a toolset that features a hammer,
nails, and straw doll effigy that has the
ability to greatly improve the user’s cursed
energy. By channeling her cursed energy
through the tools, Nobara can utilize a
number of different techniques including sharing
damage between her straw doll and her target.
These nails are sent into the user's target
using a hammer to hit and propel them
forward as projectiles. The cursed energy
allows the nails to be freely manipulated,
giving the user free range of motion
in preparation for that strike.
If the target is hit by the nails,
the cursed energy flowing through them
can be used to deal further damage.
(Resonance) Once hitting a target,
the user of straw doll manipulation
can use an extension technique. The
first of these is the Resonance,
which applies cursed energy to the user's
target using a straw doll as an effigy.
The user will generally use one body part
of their target to create the link and then
use resonance to apply damage to more critical
appendages of the opponent's body. For example,
by placing a curse's severed arm on the
straw doll and striking it with a nail
using a hammer, the nails can be used
to pierce the targeted curse's heart.
The effectiveness varies depending on the
opponents skill level, the targeted body part,
and the strength of the connection to the user's
target. If a link is made to multiple opponents,
Resonance will injure them all at the same time.
(Hairpin) The second and last extension technique
we’ve seen from the straw doll technique,
Hairpin allows the user to greatly
enhance the output of their cursed
energy. Cursed energy shrouding the
nails expands with explosive force,
highly magnifying their destructive
capabilities. I think this works by
placing a binding vow on the nails that means
they’ll be destroyed after the technique is used.
Junpei Yoshino - So im gonna stick Junpei’s thingy
in here cause I really didnt know
where to stick it in the video.
(Moon Dregs) Junpei’s Shikigami Moon
Dregs takes the form of a translucent
blue jellyfish with a body large
enough to shroud its user. It has
two black eyes and thin yellow
tentacles draping from its body.
Moon Dregs is capable of reshaping its
tentacles as well as portions of its
body to form stingers. It's also capable
of distributing poison with its attacks.
Arata Nitta - So, Kyoto Jujutsu Tech actually
has 1 first year in Arata Nitta. This dude
isn't by any means a physical fighter and is
more seen as a coordinator type. To be honest
he reminds me of a manager, probably
just due to the black suit he wears.
(Pain Killer) His ability though, Pain Killer is
a technique that allows Arata to stop existing
injuries from getting any worse. The user of
pain killer cant specifically heal wounds,
but they can stop bleeding and reduce the pain
for anyone its applied to. The downside of
this technique is mainly how it doesn't allow the
user to heal anyone, just sustain their injuries.
Mai Zenin - First of the second
years at Kyoto Tech, Mai Zenin
doesn't posses an inherited technique
like the majority of other characters,
however she does have her own one that she
created over time. This technique is also
seen in another character called Yorozu, that
makes her appearance during the culling game.
(Construction) This ability, Construction is
an inefficient technique that consumes most of
the users cursed energy to create something from
nothing. Unlike creating objects within a Domain,
things constructed by this technique will not
disappear once the spell has finished. However,
creating something from nothing uses an immense
amount of cursed energy, which results in harsh
backlash on the user's body. So depending on
how much cursed energy the user might have,
it will allow them a differing level and
complexity of things they might be able to create.
(A single Bullet)
Sadly for Mai and her pathetically
small pool of cursed energy,
all she was able to produce is a single
bullet per day. I should bring it up aswell,
but Mai was also able to create a cursed
tool sword at the cost of her life.
Some of the cooler extension techniques
that weve seen from construction come
from Yorozu and her battle
against the king of curses.
(Liquid Metal) Liquid Metal is pretty
much how it sounds, a construction of
liquid metal that changeable in shape and
volume with stable physical properties due
to the semi-autonomous cursed energy
manipulating it. This here almost
works as a base for the construction
technique to build other things off.
(Insect Armor) For example the user of this
technique could use the liquid metal to create
an Insect Armor which is specialized in adapting
a plethora of different insects abilities and
functions. Doing this will inherently help
with sustaining the users cursed energy
for a longer period of time while simultaneously
enhancing their strength, speed, and durability.
(Perfect Sphere) Lastly a user of construction
is one of the only beings able to make a perfect
sphere. By using that liquid metal and shaping
it into a sphere, the user is able to make a
perfect one. A true sphere has no contact area
and generates infinite pressure, as a result,
making it untouchable. Its kinda like
Gojo’s purple in the idea that its an
unstoppable imaginary mass of cursed energy
that will destroy anything in its path.
Kokichi Muta - Next up on the food chain of
abilities inside of Jujutsu kaisen comes from the
traitor himself Kokichi Muta. So we kind of have
a similar ability to Kokichi’s puppet manipulation
in Masamichi’s cursed corpse manipulation, but
they are different. Unlike Masamichi who can
give the doll control, Kokichi himself controls
these puppets with his adept use of cursed energy.
Sorry Maki but cause im mentioning a heavenly
restriction now, I doubt ill mention you at all!
(Heavenly Restriction) This Heavenly Restriction
is a restriction placed on someone aswell and not
a technique a person will perform themselves. Its
explained to us as a binding that is placed apon
a sorcerers body when they are born. Im not sure
if this is an otherworldly un-controllable feat,
or something the parents perform. What we do
know is that these bindings usually refer to
limitations on the human body, this could be
cursed energy related or physically related,
in exchange, the person with this
restriction receives improved capabilities.
(Puppet Manipulation) Kokichi who suffers from
an extreme example of a heavenly restriction
was gifted with vast amounts of cursed
energy that he used to control massive
amounts Mechamaru puppets remotely through Puppet
Manipulation. Puppets such as Ultimate Mechamaru
are capable of using explosive cursed energy as
plasma beams among a bevy of other abilities.
(Batto Sword Drawing) I
should mention this aswell,
even though I feel like it is more of a barrier
technique since its related to the shadow style,
but Miwa posses the ability called Batto Sword
Drawing. This ability is an iai sword-drawing
technique optimal for striking enemies
situated directly in front of the user.
It covers the blade with cursed energy and
rotates it, greatly improve the drawing speed.
Toge Inumaki - So the next 2nd year who actually
has an inherited technique is the mute legend,
big Inumaki Toge and his Cursed Speech.
(Cursed Speech) Cursed Speech
is an inherited technique of the
Inumaki Family. It reinforces the
user's words with cursed energy,
which compels the listeners to act or
be acted upon based on those words.
To execute cursed speech, the user must
use a cursed tool with a particular set
of seals on it. For example, the mute
king has seal markings on his cheeks
and tongue. Whereas the original MC Yuta
has a tool created by the Inumaki Family,
the "Serpent Eyes and Fang", which
has those same markings on it.
Cursed speech is activated when the user
utters words or commands aloud that are
reinforced with cursed energy. This action
compels the listener to act or be acted upon
as a command. For example, a cursed speech
user can command his opponent to stop moving,
or for them to be crushed. The strength of the
compulsion depends on the skill level of the user.
As Cursed Speech uses language and is a more
wild technique, it can make it dangerous to
casually speak with other people. Civilians
and anyone within the range of the user will
be affected if they accidentally hear the wrong
word. As a countermeasure, users of cursed speech
tend to limit their casual language to certain
safe words to avoid triggering cursed speech.
Panda - Back when I first mentioned Masamichi
I really didnt know if I should include this
cuddly bear as apart of his Cursed
Corpse Manipulation or have Panda as
his own person with techniques.
Obviously I decided the latter,
as this dude is his own person with
his own abilities and feelings.
(Cursed Corpse Cores) Due to him being a puppet
Panda didnt exactly have the ability to inherit
a technique, however he instead possesses
what's called Cursed Corpse Cores. Inside
of him are 3 cores, all with differing
personalities and powers. Panda's body:
the balanced and main form, the
power form called Gorilla mode,
and a third core called Triceratops mode.
At base Panda technically has 3 lives,
but if any of these cores are damaged, Panda is
unable to shift into that form until it recovers.
(Gorilla Mode) By switching to his
"brother's" core, and going Gorilla Mode,
Panda can transform into a muscular
gorilla. Panda is much stronger and
faster in this form but at the cost
of rapidly draining his cursed energy.
(Unblockable Drumming Beat) A secondary
technique available while in Gorilla Mode,
Unblockable Drumming Beat allows any strike
Panda lands to resonate through the targets
body. The idea behind this is similar
to Yuji’s divergent punch in which even
if the person blocks, they still feel some
form of secondary damage resonate through.
(Triceratops Mode) Finally by
switching to his "sister's" core,
Panda can transform into Triceratops mode.
Apparently this is the most destructive form,
but as we haven't seen to much from her
so far, all we can do is take Panda’s
word. Panda apparently claims his sister's
form destroys everyone who looks at her,
because of her shyness, however the 1
time she turned up it didnt go to well.
Yuta Okkotsu - Ahh now we get
to talk about the ability thief,
the Kakashi wannabe of jjk,
the original mc, Maki’s girl,
Big Yutta Okkotsu and the plethora of
abilities this guy’s got stored up.
(Complete Rika Manifestation) While connected to
Rika through his ring, Yuta can fully manifest the
queen of curses, use cursed techniques, and access
her supply of cursed energy to replenish his own.
Rika also has the ability to store a wide
range cursed tools and can equip them to
Yuta at will. There is a time limit to her full
manifestation though as he can only maintain a
sustained connection with Rika and remain in this
state for five minutes at a time. Im assuming
this is because the ring is like a doorway to
whatever realm the unraveled Rika now abides in.
(Copy) While connected to Rika, Yuta can copy
innate techniques and use them. He can even
use multiple different techniques that he's
copied in quick succession. Plus once copying
them while Rika is out, he can then use those
same abilities when ever. The conditions under
which he can copy a technique are not fully known,
but it is implied he gained the ability to copy
Uro's Sky Manipulation after Rika consumed
her arm. So far out of the ones weve seen,
Yuta has been able to copy; Cursed Speech,
Sky Manipulation and Thin Ice Breaker.
(Cursed Energy Blast) Yuta can only
fire a directed blast of cursed energy
when Rika is completely manifested. Together,
they can fire a beam that is just
shy of matching Ryu's Granite Blast.
Putting Uro’s abilities aside
cause ill speak more on them later.
(Shikigami) Yuta can also summon shikigami
using his hair as an intermediary. The
shikigami appear as small bats with
heads similar to that of Rika's. They
fly around the opponent to form a sphere
like domain that can slash anyone inside
it. Just incase you thought this was an
ability of his, Yuta copied this technique.
So thats all of the second
years from both schools covered,
now I guess we better touch
on the big dogs, the seniors.
Kinji Hakari - Hakari Hakari Hakari, now
I initially thought I was going to be here
for a year trying to explain this silly old
technique. Then I realized, its his domain.
(Private Pure Love Train) Hakari’s Innate
technique is called Private Pure Love Train,
this is a pachinko-themed technique that is
primarily applied through his domain expansion.
The cursed technique imbued into the domain
manifests Private Pure Love Train, a pachinko game
inspired by the previously mentioned romance manga
series. However the reason I bring it up as a solo
technique is because Hakari can summon the visual
effect indicators of the game, such as the shutter
doors outside of his domain. They can then be
used to catch, block or even damage the opponent.
Kirara Hoshi - Next up and a big lover of
the FEVER, Kirara Hoshi has one of those
techniques that just make your brain rot with
confusion. Like how do you even think this one up.
(Love Rendezvous) This technique named
Love Rendezvous assigns five "stars★" with
a Southern Cross shape in order to target
cursed energy. The five stars are ★Imai,
★Acrux, ★Mimosa, ★Ginan, and ★Gacrux.
In order to mark something with a star,
the user must make physical contact with
someone's cursed energy. Anyone that
has been marked will experience a
sparking light above their head when
the technique is activated. They can
also find the name of the star they've been
marked with written somewhere on their body.
Only one star can be placed on one person's
cursed energy at a time but the same star can
be applied to multiple different people
simultaneously. This includes the user,
so if they've marked themselves with a star,
they must remove it before then deciding to
mark another object. If the user needs to
mark multiple different objects with stars,
the objects need to be charged by
someone else's cursed energy beforehand.
Cursed energy shared between a sorcerer and
their shikigami is considered the same by
Love Rendezvous. The user can mark both the
Shikigami owner and their Shikigami with a
star at the same time. They can even place a star
on the sorcerer without touching them directly,
simply by making contact with
the Shikigami. If this happens,
the one with the higher cursed energy
output will pull the other when attracted.
Anyone marked with a star must
follow a specific order if they
want to attempt moving towards another
star. If they dont follow the ordering,
targets with the same star will attract each
other making it impossible to escape. The
determined route that you have to follow works
by following the nearest star first and finishing
at the furthest one. The order we’ve seen is
★Imai → ★Acrux → ★Mimosa → ★Ginan → ★Gacrux.
Momo Nishimiya - Time to get away from
the mind bending spatial abilities and
move onto something a bit more down to earth.
(Tool Manipulation) Momo Nishimiya is
equipped with an innate technique called
Tool Manipulation. Along with other broom related
things, this technique grants the user the ability
to levitate the tool, fly on the tool or create
gusts of powerful wind imbued with cursed energy.
(Wind Scythe) An extension of Tool
Manipulation, Wind Scythe is used
by swinging the users broom as they ride it.
This can effectively create strong gusts of
cursed energy infused wind, strong enough
to push people back or even wound them.
Aoi Todo - Do you feel it brother? I
tell you an arm is merely a decoration,
but the act of applause is the acclimation of
the soul itself. Himothy, Big Todo has one of
the most simplistic abilities inside of the verse,
but oml can he abuse the absolute hell out of it.
(Boogie Woogie) Boogie Woogie the body switching
ability activates when the user claps their
hands together. The technique switches the
positions of the user and anything they desire,
all they need to do is make sure
whatever they intend to switch,
has some level of cursed energy. They
dont have to always switch themselves
as the user can also switch other peoples
locations as long as they have cursed energy.
Noritoshi Kamo & Big Bro Choso - So that
is kinda all we know about Boogie Woogie,
there really isnt too much to it like
some of the other ones. Another of these
highly complex abilities comes from a
duo you could almost call father and
son... The Blood Manipulation of
Noritoshi Kamo and Big Bro Choso.
(Blood Manipulation) As it implies, Blood
Manipulation is a cursed technique that
allows the user to control and shape their
blood beyond its natural form or motion
for a variety of effects. It can be used to
manipulate every aspect of the user's blood,
including blood composition, internal blood flow,
plasma, pulse rate, body temperature and red blood
cells. It also allows them to control the blood
externally as long as it belongs to the user.
External blood can be hardened or
shaped to create mid-range projectiles.
As with any cursed technique, Blood Manipulation's
efficiency and strength depend on who wields
it. With this technique we’ve seen two vastly
different people use it. In my personal opinion
and due to him being human Noritoshi Kamo's use of
blood manipulation falls short to that of Choso.
This is mainly for the fact that the user is
limited by the amount of their own blood they have
access to. Too much blood loss could obviously
result in death, so users generally prepare
blood bags or weapons dipped in their blood
in advance. Unless your built like Choso. Also
another factor of blood manipulation is that
the blood is poisonous to cursed spirits.
(Flowing Red Scale) The first of many
extension techniques, Flowing Red Scale,
Increases the user's body temperature, pulse
rate, and the number of red blood cells to
give themselves greatly increased
energy and physical capabilities.
(Flowing Red Scale: Stack) Flowing Red Scale:
Stack Intensifies Flowing Red Scale in order to
increase the user's physical capabilities
to an even higher degree than normally.
(Crimson Binding) Third of this
techniques extension techniques,
Crimson Binding Transforms blood into a
widespread net that tightly ensnares the target.
(Slicing Exorcism) Slicing Exorcism
is a long-range attack that allows
the user to slice or shoot
their opponent. It can take
the form of a quickly rotating disc
of blood or a long stream of blood.
(Convergence) Convergence is a baseline
technique within blood manipulation. This
technique is mainly used first in combination
with others to perform an extension technique.
Convergence is achieved when blood is compressed
and condensed to its limit between the palms
of the user. From that a compressed blood
sphere will be formed. Because it requires
time to apply Convergence to blood, user is
vulnerable against fast and quick attacks.
(Piercing Blood) After using Convergence,
a few options are available for a blood
manipulation user. One of these, Piercing
Blood applies that compressed blood and uses
it in a long ranged beam of blood that will
pretty much go through anything it touches.
Once skillfully reinforced with cursed
energy, it can reach the speed of sound,
however any subsequent movement will
cause it to slow. This ability is so
deadly that if you get hit by it without
expecting the attack, you will be pierced.
(Supernova) Another option available
after using Convergence is Supernova.
To do this the user will create
multiple small orbs of blood,
then have those said orbs shoot out in
every direction like a buckshot. These
smaller orbs of blood are somewhat hardened,
adding to the damage someone might receive.
(Blood Edge) A quick utilization of Blood
Manipulations ability to harden blood,
Blood Edge strengthens the user's blood
density by rotating it at a high speed.
(Blood Meteorite) Using some of those same
properties, Blood Meteorite is used when the
user hardens some of their blood, to an almost
crystalized level, before throwing it at their
target. Its most lethal within short ranges as
the speed will drastically decrease overtime.
Suguru Geto - Moving on from one
manipulator to another though,
Suguru Geto and then subsequently Kenjaku
have both been seen in use of this technique.
(Cursed Spirit Manipulation) As the name
suggests, Cursed Spirit Manipulation is a
technique where like the Ten Shadows
Technique, one can control a being,
in this example a cursed spirit they were able
to conquer in battle. Rather than exorcise the
cursed spirit, the user can absorb them into
a small black sphere before consuming them.
Orally consuming this orb gives the
user complete dominance over the curse,
allowing them to summon them
at any time in the future.
If the difference in grade is two levels or more,
the curse manipulator can absorb a cursed spirit
with practically no conditions attached.
The user can extract the curse technique
from semi-grade 1 and above cursed spirits they
absorb, providing them with an immense arsenal of
potential different moves. However, the quality
of the cursed spirit's technique ceases to grow
the moment they are absorbed and the user can
only use that Technique once. For example this
is what Kenjaku’s plan was during Shibuya, the
growth of Mahito to such a high degree that he
could absorb him and use a country-wide idle
transfiguration, starting the culling game.
Like I mentioned before, Cursed Spirit
Manipulation operates functionally the
same as Shikigami conjuring. However, no
intermediary like a hand sign is required.
There doesn't appear to be any limit on the
number of curses that can be absorbed and it
is unknown what happens to the cursed
spirits taken in after the user dies.
(Maximum: Uzumaki) A possible way to rid
ones self of all these curses though,
is through the users Maximum Technique:
Uzumaki. This ability takes all of the
cursed spirits that the user of cursed spirit
manipulation has absorbed and merges them into
one. Initially I thought this was a beam like
ability, but Uzumaki itself takes the form of
a swirling cursed spirit that levitates
behind the user. Once unleashed, it darts
forward to whatever was targeted and unleashes a
powerful attack of super condensed cursed energy.
Mimiko Hasaba -78 (Teddy Noose)
Moving forward again and I didn't
know this before doing some research, but
Mimiko's technique Teddy Noose allows her
to hang her targets using a noose. Hence
those hung managers throughout Shibuya!
Although the exact mechanics of how it
works is unknown, Mimiko's technique
involves the usage of both the rope and her
stuffed childhood toy that she keeps on her.
Nanako Hasaba - 77(Camera Phone) One
of the more modern implementations of
a cursed technique is shown when we see
Nanako try and snap a picture of Sukuna.
Nanako's technique Camera Phone allows her
to manipulate a photographed subject that
she takes an image of using the camera
on her cellphone. She once used it on
herself to dodge one of Jogo’s attacks,
but the process tired her out quickly.
(Knives Out) Bayer - So the only member from
the cursed user group Q to have an ability
that we somewhat might know is Bayer and those
knives of his. Im calling this ability Knives
out cause it sounds dope, but im assuming
that its some sort of Tool Manipulation
like ability in which he can freely
manipulate knives with cursed energy.
(Professional Sorcerers)
Kento Nanami - I think its fitting that
with the very first professional sorcerers
techniques that we go over, we start with
the model example of what a grade 1 Jujutsu
Sorcerer is. The big Man Kento Nanami and
his ability to Ratio the hell out of anyone.
(Ratio Technique) A user of Ratio Technique
is able to mark their target's body with lines
divided into tenths. If the user is able to strike
one of these lines on exactly the seven-to-three
ratio point, they deliver a critical hit to the
subject. This allows them to deal significant
damage on stronger opponents and absolutely
body the hell out of anyone weaker than them.
The lines don't have to measure
up to the target's full length,
height or wingspan. Their head, torso, biceps,
and forearms are all area’s that someone with
this technique can individually target.
On top of that, the technique doesn't have
to be used on curses or people, and can even
be used on inanimate objects like buildings.
(Collapse) The only extension technique that
we’ve seen a user of the Ratio ability use is,
Collapse. Instead of a singular target, Collapse
expands the overall target area of what can be
hit by the ratio technique. Simply, it creates
a weak point in the surrounding environment,
allowing the user to deliver a critical hit
and destroy it. The impact of this technique
is so powerful it creates shockwaves of cursed
energy that rips through its effective hit zone.
For anyone wondering why I haven't
mentioned overtime and revealing ones hand,
well those are just binding vows and ill go
over all of the binding vows in another video.
Takuma Ino - Extremely fitting to
stick these two people and their
abilities together, as this guy here Takuma
Ino im pretty sure was either some kind of
student or friend to Nanami before becoming
a professional sorcerer. Even now he still
insists that Nanami is the only person
to recommend him for the role of grade 1.
(Auspicious Beast Summon) Takuma’s Technique
though Auspicious Beast Summon is extremely
interesting as it plays into the idea of
summoning a soul from another world. The
ABS is a type of séance technique that
when the users face is hidden from view,
transforms them into a spiritual medium
for that beast. From what we’ve seen,
people with this Technique can bring forth
the power of the auspicious beasts numbers
one thru four. Each of the beasts abilities
are manifested by the user's cursed energy,
and can be summoned by calling out
the desired beast's name and number.
Unlike Shikigami or Cursed Spirit Manipulation,
Auspicious Beast Summon does not create spirits
to fight alongside their master. Instead,
the abilities of the Auspicious Beasts are
materialized through cursed energy
for the user to utilize themselves.
(Kaichi) Auspicious Beast number one, Kaichi
summons a horn with a spiral pattern on it. It can
be fired as a homing projectile cloaked in cursed
energy that won't stop until it hits its target.
(Reiki) The second Auspicious Beast, Reiki
Covers Ino's body in cursed water that
can be used to cushion him from danger
and or increases his overall mobility.
(Kirin) Auspicious Beast Number Three
Kirin pretty much allows the user to
fight with a massively reduced sense of
pain. This will drain the users stamina
simultaneously making them extremely
tired, and completely unable to fall
asleep. Once the beast has been summoned and
whatever was needed to be done is completed,
the user wont be able to function for a limited
amount of time. We’ve never actually seen the
use of this beast, so i've only been able
to go off what Ino’s said about its powers.
(Ryu) Another of the beasts we haven't really
seen but know a little about. Auspicious Beast
number four, Ryu was about to be used
in Ino’s battle against the Séance user,
However Toji Zenin got his ass. Up to
that point, nobody had ever survived
to tell the tale after fighting Ryu...
Once again according to Ino thooo haha!
Mei Mei - Time for big sis and the creepy brother
that follows her around everywhere. Man is
desperate. Ofcourse im talking about Mei Mei and
her dope ability called Black Bird Manipulation.
(Black Bird Manipulation) So as you’ve seen,
Black Bird Manipulation allows the user to
imbue crows with cursed energy and control them
at will. Im not sure if its specifically crows,
but it seems that way. The user of this ability
can manipulate multiple crows at the same time.
Additionally, the user can also share vision
with the birds, making the technique perfect
for surveillance. The crows that have been imbued
with cursed energy are under absolute control,
so if needed they can be used to strike the
opponent, even at the cost of the bird's own life.
(Bird Strike) That brings us to the one extension
technique we’ve seen Mei Mei use with Black
bird Manipulation, Bird Strike. In order to
exceed the limits of the normally weak crows,
a Black Bird Manipulator can force
their crows to commit no life. By
hurling a crow imbued with cursed
energy beyond its normal limits,
the user can unleash a devastating attack that
is normally a one-hit finisher. Apparently and
according to Mei Mei, the only person able
to stop it is Gojo. But that might be cap.
Ui Ui - When it comes to Ui Ui the specifics of
his innate technique are unknown. Mei Mei said
it allowed them both to escape a battle by
transferring them from Japan to Malaysia.
(Gateway) So im legit just gonna go ahead
and say he has some form of teleportation
or gateway like ability. Adding more credence
to this, his technique also allowed him to act
as someone who could communicate with
people inside and outside of barriers.
Yuki Tsukumo - Someone who
doesn't cap in the slightest,
and even decided to mentally ruin
Suguru Geto with her talk-no Jutsu,
then beat the ass of the guy who stole his
body. OFCOURSE im talking about the QUEEN
and most powerful professional sorcerer, the
special grade, Yuki Tsukumo and her star rage.
(Garuda) First thing I need to mention is
that this technique has a Shikigami called
Garuda associated with it, its 100% apart of
the technique so im just gonna label it as an
extension. Garuda can have virtual mass added
to it using Star Rage, as it's the only thing
affected by the cursed technique other than
the user. What makes it even more confusing,
is that Star Rage transforms Garuda into a cursed
tool that the user can use in battle. Garuda can
also act and fight independently regardless;
whether or not Star Rage is active as well.
(Star Rage) When it comes to
her main technique, Star Rage,
the primary function of it is to empower its user
with the ability to add mass to themselves and
the shikigami associated with this technique.
The mass added is virtual or imaginary, but it
always increases the user's physical attacks with
force equal to the real mass assigned to them.
The added mass doesn't weigh
down the user or its Shikigami,
but it also doesn't increase their
body's overall weight aswell.
However there is a density threshold to
how much virtual or imaginary mass the
user can stack on themselves. If taken to
far and they add way to much mass/density
to themselves it will condense their body
into a black hole with extreme gravity,
ripping everything around into it. This is
no question one of the strongest abilities
in the series, it just sucks we never got
to see it used in more than 2 battles.
Naobito Zenin & Naoya Zenin - When it comes to
the Zenin Family, they’re meant to be known for
the Ten Shadows Technique. However none of the
main families current family members were born
with that inherited technique. Instead the eldest
and youngest males of the family, Naobito and
Naoya had a secondary inherited
technique, projection sorcery.
(Projection Sorcery) Just like in an anime
sequence, movie or animation, this technique
divides one second into twenty-four frames of
animation using the user's field of view as the
projection angle. To perform the ability, the user
will trace a predetermined set of movements that
take place over 24 frames and execute them in a
single second. Due to how this technique works,
it makes the user appear to move
unnaturally fast, too quick for
even special grade cursed spirits to follow,
however this is technically just a fallacy.
While Projection Sorcery is active
and the sorcerer is in movement,
anything touched by the user's palm must also
abide by the "24 FPS" and copy those same
movements. If the opponent doesn't follow these
specific rules, it results in the subject getting
immobilized and frozen in an animation frame
for one second. Although it's just a second,
anything caught in that frame is completely
vulnerable to attack, allowing people to land
free hits. Hitting the frame will break the target
out of it. Catching someone in a frame wont do any
damage in itself, so the sorcerer using this
ability still needs to be somewhat strong.
After the user decides on their movements,
the predetermined course cannot be adjusted.
On top of that, if the trajectory of movement
or the laws of physics are excessively ignored,
the user will be frozen in a frame for one second.
Ogi Zenin - Next up and brother to Naobito, Ogi
Zenin always thought he was unlucky and hard
done by in life. He never received the Ten Shadows
Technique or projection Sorcerery and was always
outclassed by his brother. Still.. Somehow he
thought he was the one who deserved to be the head
of the family, and thats why I think he decided
to name his Innate Technique: Blazing Courage.
62(Blazing Courage) Blazing Courage allows
the user to ignite flames of cursed energy
and channel them through their weapon to
create a flaming sword. Blazing Courage
can be used to replace a broken blade and
can even slice through objects as a sword
would. If the user infuses more
cursed energy into the technique,
it will generate scorching flames that
encircle them and coat their blade.
Ranta Zenin - Next up out of the people inside
of the Zenin Clan with some form of Technique,
so dont expect to hear about the Kukuru
Squad, Ranta Zenin and his Paralyzing Gaze.
(Paralyzing Gaze) Pretty much from what we
could see, Paralyzing Gaze is an ability
that catches anyone the user gazes upon
in an immobilizing aura. On top of that,
large eyes that emit the Paralyzing Gaze are
imagined behind the opponent. These eyes work
as an intermediary between the sorcerer and
opponent. So if someone manages to break the
hold and in turn those eyes, it could
backfire with devastating consequences.
Jinichi Zenin - Next up out of the Zenin’s,
Jinichi and his massive missile fists technique.
(Missile Fists) As the name implies,
Missile Fists is an extremely destructive
technique in which the user is able to
conjure a number of giant firsts that are
propelled by cursed energy, like a missile.
Chojuro Zenin - Lastly out
of the Zenin family members,
Chojuro Zenin and his ability
to manipulate the earth.
(Earth Arms) Chojuro's Earth Arms technique
allows him to manipulate the earth to some
degree. To do this, the user touches
the ground with both hands and activates
the ability. From what we’ve seen, its
only able to create large stone hands,
but im sure there’s probably some more
utility to it we never got to see.
Ryomen Sukuna - Moving on from the Zenin’s and
when it comes to the king of curses himself, it is
currently unknown what Sukuna's cursed technique
is called. Throughout the series he’s been shown
to use his cursed energy to perform two types of
slashes. The reason we dont know if this is his
innate technique or not is because he has such
a high level of control over cursed energy. Most
characters will take days to unlock a new ability,
for Sukuna though all it takes is one glance at
how it was achieved to do it himself. On top of
the base standard slashing attacks Sukuna was seen
using, he’s also been shown to use fire-based
powers that originate from another dimension.
(Dismantle) When it comes to the slashing attacks
though, Dismantle is an attack that is normally
used for inanimate objects. This attack doesn't
work on cursed spirits or sorcerers, unless they
are no longer considered alive. It may also work
on Maki as CE see’s her as an inanimate object.
(Cleave) Secondary of the two slashing
attacks, Cleave is an attack that adjusts
the level of cursed energy needed depending on the
target's toughness, to cut them down in one go.
(Fire Arrow) Possibly an otherworldly
ability or even his Innate Technique,
Fire Arrow is an ability that allows the user
to open some form of black box to create and
manipulate flames. These flames are then
formed into an arrow and shot at whoever
the intended target it. Throughout the series, not
a single person has ever survived these flames.
(Spiderweb) After gaining Megumi’s body, we
saw the king of curses use a multitude of new
abilities that we hadn't seen him use before.
The first of these, Spiderweb allows the user
to utilize the Cleave but in a spiderweb like
pattern. As a variation of Cleave, this technique
can also adjust its destructive force to take out
the intended opponent or surroundings in one blow.
When it comes to the Ten Shadows Technique,
Sukuna actually expanded on what we originally
knew was even possible. He made
the technique seem otherworldly,
and even summoned other Shikigami
we never saw Megumi conjure up.
(Piercing Ox) The first of these ancient
Shikigami, Piercing Ox is as the name
says an ox shikigami that can charge down
opponents with frightening speed. Due to
how we’ve seen it summoned, it can only move
in a straight line, but the longer its charge,
the more powerful its hit will be. Its
also extremely robust and was able to
take a few blows from a special grade
Heian period sorcerer before vanishing.
(Round Deer) Second is the Round Deer, this
beast is a towering deer shikigami that can
automatically heal itself and the master through
reverse cursed technique. The positive cursed
energy that flows through the Shikigami, is
powerful enough to cause another sorcerer to
lose control of whatever they might be doing.
Ofcourse aswell, with it being positive energy
and like Mahoraga id say Round Deer is a
great option for battling cursed spirits.
(Nue: Totality - Merged Beast Agito) Lastly out of
the extra add in’s to the Ten Shadows Technique,
is an improved humanoid version of the
Nue. This Merged Beast Agito inherited
the powers of the Great Serpent, Tiger
Funeral, and Round Deer. It is a large,
powerful shikigami capable of producing
electricity and regenerating lost limbs
with reverse cursed technique. This
RCT can also work on its master.
(Tiger Funeral) Also I mise aswell mention it,
but we did technically get the 10th Shikigami
revealed to us. Its name Tiger Funeral doesn't
really give much away apart from the fact its
got something to do with a tiger. So yeah.
Master Tengen - Over to the oldest lady in
the history of Jujutsu Kaisen, big Thumgen.
(Immortality) So being the oldest
person in the verse, Tengen has the
ability of immortality. This technique
obviously grants the user eternal life,
however it does not stop the aging process.
In order to keep living past this point,
their body and technique must be
reset every five hundred years.
Kenjaku/Noritoshi Kamo - Moving onto the previous
lover of Tengen and the BACKSHOT KING. Kenjaku
has been around for as long, if not longer
because of his special ability, Body Swapping.
(Body Swapping) Kenjaku's innate technique
allows him to swap bodies with another person,
even if they are dead, by transplanting his brain
into the body of his target. After the transplant,
this technique leaves a stitched scar
running across the users head. The user
is at anytime able to remove the top part
of their head and reveal their true self.
Once inside a body, the user of body swapping
will gain access to the host's cursed energy,
all their innate techniques, and
memories. Even the Six Eyes wont
be able recognize him as an imposter since
he has the original users cursed energy.
As shown with his usage of Kaori technique
while fighting against Choso and Yuki,
its been hinted that even when switching to a
new body, a body swapping user retains access
and usage of his former host’s innate cursed
techniques. This cant be abused to much though,
as the limit of former hosts innate
techniques the user can store is upto 4.
(Antigravity System) One of these stolen innate
techniques from a former host, The Antigravity
System is freaking broken. The exact function
of how Kaori Itadori’s technique worked still
isn't fully explored, so its hard to exactly pin
down how Kenjaku’s version of it might work. But
what we all need to understand is that what we
saw is him use is the Reversal of her cursed
technique. In theory im assuming that Kaori’s
Anti Gravity turned off the gravity around her
and allowed the user to send people shooting off
in some sort of vacuum. What we all saw was the
reversal of that where the user instead forces
an insane amount of gravitational forces down
for approximately 6 seconds. On top of that, the
gravitational forces dont seem to effect the user,
but are able to stop the effects of pretty much
any ability, including a freaking black hole.
This ability, just because of how unknown
it still is seems so interesting to me,
and id love to see it get another feature in
an upcoming battle so we can find out more. The
fact that this could be an ability Yuji might have
because his mum had it aswell is mental, like is
it possible dude could go from having no abilities
to just being stacked up. Id love to know your
thoughts on this one down below for sure and if
you think I miss understood it let me know haha!
Uraume - Sticking with the other members
of Kenjaku’s squad and someone who
actually turned out to be Sukuna’s
close acquaintance. The ice Queen,
Uraume has one of the most versatile
abilities in the series, Ice Formation.
(Ice Formation) As you could imagine, this ice
based technique allows the user to lower the
temperature around them to extreme levels.
These freezing temperatures then allow them
to produce ice and frost at will. The user
can generate multiple sheets of solid ice by
simply touching a surface. They can also manifest
other forms of ice such as a cloud of frozen mist,
or a massive block of ice that falls from the
sky. Any ice or extremely cold substance can
also freely manipulated by the user, allowing
them to only use their mind to send attacks.
(Frost Calm) A baseline ability of Ice formation,
Frost Calm lowers the temperature of the air
around the user, allowing them to channel a
frosted mist to their hand. The user then brings
their hand up to their mouth and blows on that
frozen mist. This in turn creates a cloud of
icy mist that shoots towards their target.
As the cloud of icy mist move’s forward,
anything that it touches instantly gets frozen
enabling the user to trap their opponent. While
trapped and covered in several layers of ice,
one wrong move might result in them getting cut
by the razer sharp icicles that now surround them.
(Icefall) Just like with the previous technique,
Icefall allows the user to lower the temperature
of air around their hand, covering it with a thin
layer of ice. With this extremely low temperature,
the Ice Formation user is able to generate
massive amounts of ice on any surface they touch.
On top of that, the user can break apart the
ice using their mind and levitate it through
the air. If they managed to hit their opponent,
the user can freeze their target on contact,
covering their body with
a thick layer of hard ice.
Once trapped again, the users
opponents are finished off
by large icicles that fly forth
and skewer their frozen bodies.
Haruta Shigemo - Next up on the list,
we got the creeper king himself,
big Haruta Shigemo and his
crazy innate technique Miracles.
(Miracles) I think its pretty obvious
here that Gege needed someone to beat on,
so he legit created a technique that
revolved around miracles. The idea for
this technique works by erasing all of the
little every day miracles one might have
(like seeing a clock randomly hit all the
same digits) along with the memory of it,
from Haruta's life and stores them away. Once
stored away, these lines appear under his eyes
with a Maximum of 6 miracles being allowed per
day. These stored miracles are released when
Haruta's life is in danger, altering his luck
to ensure he survives lethal events. Finally,
when a miracle has been used, the marking
turns to white, signifying that its empty.
Jiro Awasaka - Weirdly when it comes to people
that can take a hit head on and make it seem as
though they're absolutely fine after. Jiro Awasaka
and his Inverse technique is the perfect example.
(Inverse) While activated Inverse makes it
so all damage attacks against the user are
reversed. Simply enough, strong blows
become weak and weak ones become strong
while the technique is activated. Due to
how ridiculous it would be if this technique
inversed everything on the user, there is a
minimum and maximum limit to its conditions.
Ogami - Fourth and final from Kenjaku’s
group to have a known technique, Ogami with
her séance technique came into the story during
shibuya and absolutely flipped it on its head.
(Séance Technique) The Séance Technique grants
the user the ability to contact the dead and
summon their body or soul's information to the
living world. This is done by having someone
consume apart of a deceased sorcerer, while
the user performs a ritual. Transforming into
someone using their body's information allows the
shape-shifter to utilize their physical abilities.
The technique is supposed to signal its own end
when the shape-shifter's cursed energy runs out,
however there can be complications
if the wrong person is resurrected.
Hajime Kashimo - Once we entered the culling game,
Mr Gege Akutami decided to introduce a flurry of
new characters that have some of the most exciting
cursed techniques seen yet. One of these guys
and probably the strongest re-incarnation, Hajime
Kashimo had a one use innate technique that would
subsequently end his life once it finishes.
To enable himself to fight without having to
rely on this technique, the ancient sorcerer took
advantage of his unique electrified cursed energy.
(Lightning Discharge) A side effect of his
cursed energy, so its not really a cursed
technique, but Lightning Discharge works by
applying a positive charge to his target,
the user is then able to discharge the negative
charge without having any of that electricity hit
the ground. In turn this creates a powerful
lightning like ability that cuts through the
sky and is almost guaranteed to anyone in its
way. The only way they’d actually dodge is if
they could physically move faster than
lightning though, so its fairly lethal.
(Mythical Beast Amber) When it comes to his one
time use innate technique, Mythical Beast Amber,
it is a release technique that reconstructs the
users body in order to bring forth any effect
that can be created by electricity. Once activated
it cant be deactivated and will use up all of the
cursed energy that user had, as the users body
will evolve into something far beyond the human
form. There isn't any specific extension ability
connected with this attack, just side effects.
These side effects increase the brains activity
making it work faster, optimize sound and tuning
waves to match normal frequencies and vaporize
irradiated objects using electromagnetic waves.
Hiromi Higuruma - Next up we’ve got the actual
G himself and Yuji’s new right hand battle man,
Hiromi Higuruma and his innate
technique Deadly Sentencing.
(Deadly Sentencing) Since Deadly Sentencing is
linked to the users Domain Expansion by default
ill just slightly mention it. If you want more
ill make a video going over every known Domain
Expansion, binding vow and ive already done
barrier techniques if you wanna check that out
here! Either way, Deadly Sentencing manifests a
small courtroom domain surrounded by guillotines
where the user and their opponent are placed
on podiums standing across from one other. This
domain does not use a guaranteed hit, instead,
anyone inside is simply forced to follow its
rules. Following with the law type theme of his
domain, it also incorporates a Shikigami known as
Judgeman, who obviously takes that judge roll. As
it may suggest, Deadly Sentencing is a court based
technique where the target is placed on a stand
and interrogated. If found guilty they could face
a multitude of different consequences,
with the worst being the death penalty.
Hana Kurusu - On a lighter note and someone who’s
able to rid the darkness from peoples hearts.
(Technique Nullification) Hana Kurusu is able
to wield Angel's innate technique, known as
nullification. Pretty much, this technique is
able nullify any and all curses, including cursed
techniques, barriers and seals. In addition, the
user might be able to revert incarnated humans
whose bodies have been fused with cursed objects,
back to their original state. There are a lot of
complications with this though, and it would most
likely result in the original vessels body dying.
(Maximum Output Technique: Jacobs Ladder) When
it comes to Hana’s Maximum Output Technique:
Jacobs Ladder. This ability conjures a four-winged
trumpet made of light under the users mouth,
then an enormous magic circle of light in
the sky above the users head. This magical
circle then features a large heptagram or
7 pointed star in its middle and crosses
along its outer edge. Upon sounding the
trumpet, the user creates a beam of light
that shoots down from the middle of the
circle to engulf whatever is below. Any
cursed technique will be "extinguished" under
the light, and incarnation is also susceptible,
as proven when Sukuna's host body
started corroding upon being struck.
Fumihiko Takaba - Ahh the LEGEND, BIG FUMIHIKO
TAKABA and his insane innate technique Comedian.
(Comedian) This technique is freaking broken,
So in short it allows the user to manifest
whatever they think is funny into reality. The
effects of this technique cover a wide variety,
including but not being limited to: conjuring
objects or substances from nothing, healing
themselves without the use of Reverse Cursed
Technique, and nullifying damage done to them.
Despite the extraordinary power
granted by this technique,
Comedian can only be activated if the
user remains confident and certain in
their ability to be funny. As a result, if
the user loses confidence in their humor,
the technique will be deactivated and
render them vulnerable to attacks.
Hanyu - Time for the Hair extension
cursed technique users, Hanyu and Haba
(Airplane Hair) Hanyu's cursed technique
Airplane hair changes the users hair into
the shape of a jet plane with 2 boosters
strong enough to propel someone through
the air at high-speed. Other sections
of a Airplane Hair users body are less
protected by cursed energy and therefore
vulnerable while the technique is active.
(Helicopter Hair) Just like Hanyu, Haba's cursed
technique, Helicopter Hair changed his hair into
a propeller with four blades. By activating it,
a user of Helicopter hair can fly around and
suspend themselves in the air with ease. They’re
also able to adjust the length and angle of their
propellers, as well as increase its rotational
speed and toughness. Like Hanyu, it is likely that
Haba's cursed energy is mainly focused on his hair
making him susceptible to body attacks aswell.
Remi - I actually completely forgot
to add this person in to start with,
so luckily on a second check through I remembered
that Remi is actually apart of this hair
manipulation gang with her scorpion hair.
(Scorpion Hair) Remi's technique Scorpion
Hair allows the user manipulate their hair
into a scorpion like tail that can attack their
opponents. Sadly for users of this technique,
it seems to be extremely weak. However that was
probably just due to Remi’s lack of cursed energy.
Reggie Star - Following the hair manipulators
we’ve got the man who’s able to dupe the absolute
hell out of any receipts he finds. No need
to buy anything when you’ve got Reggie Star
and his Contractual Recreation technique
to just make it out of thin air for you!
(Contractual Recreation) As the name suggests,
contractual recreation uses contracts such as
receipts to produce anything written on them.
This manifests the main or most expensive item
off of those receipts. It can produce
pretty much anything written on them,
but from we’ve seen, tend to be items or
services. An item could be anything from
a TV to an axe, whereas a service might
be a getaway retreat or spa vacation that
the user could instantly activate
and take the healing effects from.
Things the user re-creates sort of act
like a Shikigami with given commands.
For example if someone summons
a few missiles with a receipt,
they can be ordered with their mind to do
a certain action. After they finish this
action though, that summoning will
disappear and no longer be usable.
In order to activate Contractual Re-Creation,
the user must apply their cursed energy to
the contract or receipt and burn it. The
downside to this technique is that water
heavily de-buffs the sorcerer. If they
happen to get any of the receipts wet,
then it will be almost impossible
to ignite them with cursed energy.
Iori Hazenoki - Number 2, or who im
assuming could be considered the second
strongest sorcerer inside of Reggie’s
group, Iori Hazenoki is an extremely
durable character who only recently
kicked the bucked thanks to Kenjaku.
(Explosive Flesh) Hazenoki's innate
technique Explosive Flesh allows him
to remotely detonate his own body parts and
use them as bombs. To do this a user of the
Explosive Flesh technique can remove parts
of their body and throw them as projectiles
that will explode on command. To stop a user
of this ability running out of limbs before
they even make it out of pre-school,
a reversed cursed technique to replace
the lost body parts makes it simple for a
user of this ability to regrow anything.
Chizuru Hari - Most forgettable
from Reggie’s group, just due to
how quickly Megumi dunked on this
dude, Chizuru Hari has probably one
of the most useless techniques that make
an appearance during the culling game.
(Claws) Chizuru's technique Claws allows
him to shift his fingers into dark claws.
Its hard to say if the offensive side to
this ability had any effect while fighting,
as the dude really never got to show
it off. Pretty much all we got to see
was that users of this ability can
also climb walls using their claws.
Ryu Ishigori - Finally someone with a little
bit of potency again. The LEGEND himself and
man with the largest cursed energy output
in the entire culling game, Ryu Ishigori.
(Cursed Energy Discharge) Ryu’s Technique, Cursed
Energy Discharge is a pretty straightforward
technique. It allows the user to discharge
directed beams of compressed cursed energy
like a cannon. In order to fire, the blast has
to be charged up in order to build up a larger
enough concentration of cursed energy into a
single point. The strength of the outputted
blast depends on how much time was allowed for
it to build up. Then finally once it does fire,
the beams can take several forms depending
on the user's desires. For example, cursed
energy can be fired as a full power blast
capable of decimating several city blocks,
or a volley of rapid fire blasts
to take out the user's target.
(Granite Blast) Granite Blast is the most powerful
and straightforward application of cursed energy
discharge. It is a long ranged, extremely powerful
blast wave of highly concentrated cursed energy,
that can easily destroy an entire city
block. The more cursed energy that is
charged into Granite Blast, the larger
and more deadly its attack range becomes.
Takako Uro - Next up we’ve got the series longest
living hater and someone who just cant let things
go, Takako Uro and her Sky Manipulation Technique.
(its been like 400 years and first thing she does
each time she see’s some strong dude is
accuse them of being a Fujiwara scumbag)
(Sky Manipulation) Either way! Takako's technique
grants her the ability to "control the sky",
hence Sky Manipulation. A user of this ability
can turn the sky into a tangible surface and use
it to manipulate space, similar to how a lens
creates distortion. Im gonna chuck this in here
cause I think it helps with understanding the
technique some more. Distortion commonly occurs
from deviations or anomalies near the edges of an
image. Each type of distortion usually develops
through different variables. Barrel distortion,
for example, is often the result of a lens at
full zoom, while pincushion distortion
occurs most often from telephoto lenses.
A user of Sky Manipulation can casually uses it
to levitate themselves and hide behind
portions of manipulated sky. In battle,
a user can defend themselves by distorting the
shape of the sky around their opponent's attacks.
(Thin Ice Breaker) The surfaces a sky
manipulator controls can't crush anyone
directly, so instead a user can break
the surface of the sky with an attack
called Thin Ice Breaker. This ability
creates a shattering effect that cracks
the surface of the sky like thin ice and hits
the target with some form of multiplied force.
Charles Bernard - Last out of the new
culling game players who were introduced,
and someone who is, in my opinion
a Gege Akutami self insert,
Charles Bernard and his Manga
styled technique, G Warstaff.
(G Warstaff) Okay so the G Warstaff is actually
a cursed tool that is tied directly to Charles’s
innate technique. Due to him being a
mangaka, the item is a long spear with a
pen-shaped tip. By hitting their opponent
and getting some blood on the pens tip,
a user of this technique can fulfill the condition
for "ink". After which, they can use that ink to
mark their opponent with a manga panel. This panel
is taken directly from 1 seconds in the future,
allowing the user to see their opponents upcoming
actions. If a user of G war staff can draw more
blood from their opponent, then it will increase
the amount of time they can peer into the future.
Kechizu & Eso - Moving on now from the
techniques that were introduced to us
through-out the culling game, along with just
sorcerers in general. In this last section we
will delve into all of the techniques seen from
cursed spirits so far inside of Jujutsu Kaisen.
Also im pretty sure that only special grade
and the death paintings have cursed techniques,
so this list isn't nearly as large as the human
side of things. Starting things off though,
and just due to them sharing a bunch of
techniques, is brothers Eso and Kechizu.
(Rot Technique) So both Eso and Kechizu
possessed the Rot Technique. This ability
plays on the curses dark and toxic blood. Simply,
it is poisonous to humans and corrodes anything
it touches, capable of burning skin on impact and
eating away at solid rock. This here is probably
due to their half human side being from the Kamo
clan and having that affinity in their blood.
Additionally, utilizing the
Rot Technique also grants the
user the ability to manipulate their
blood in various ways. The blood can
be shaped into weapons or used to poison
someone and decay their body over time.
(Decay) Speaking of Decay, Decay was a
technique both of the brothers possessed.
This ability creates a floral pattern on
the target that quickly beings eating away
at their body. Anyone who takes in the blood
of a Rot Technique user through membranes or
wounds can be effected with this technique. This
can also spread to other people if accidentally
touched. Sorcerers afflicted by this are said
to be killed in less than fifteen minutes.
(Maximum: Wing King) Last of the cursed wombs
known techniques, Rot Technique Maximum:
Wing King which was only seen from Eso,
manipulates the user's blood and shapes
it into large wasp-like wings. These wings
can be used to create paths made of blood
which can be used for offensive purposes or to
increase the user's maneuverability. When the
lines of blood connect with their target,
they're instantly burned by the corrosive
effects of the blood. This in turn will
afflict them with the Decay technique.
Ganesha - When it comes to
the special grade curses,
some of them have the most complex abilities
in the series. One of those curses, Ganesha
has a technique that is able to target
concepts itself, whatever that means.
(Obstacle Removal) Just due to how short
of a time the curse was in the story,
the ins and outs of how Obstacle Removal work
isn't exactly known. Kenjaku described Ganesha’s
ability as the power to remove obstacles
and target concepts. So im assuming that
the curse itself is probably able to remove
anything from an area and place it another.
Along with targeting the idea or concept behind
a cursed technique. For example Kenjaku had the
curse use its removal ability to remove a bunch of
dudes blocking his path in the white house. Then
in its battle against Yuki the curse tried to
target and remove the concept of her technique,
however the overwhelming mass was too
much and the curse failed to do so.
Kurourushi - Second of the known
special grade curses in the list,
Kurourushi the cockroach is
an utterly terrifying force.
(Cursed Cockroaches) Kurourushi’s cursed
technique cursed cockroaches can produce
and manipulate countless swarms of real
cockroaches reinforced by its cursed
energy. These man-eating cockroaches
are able to strip the flesh off a
group of humans in a matter of seconds.
Doing this actually feeds Kurourushi's
endless appetite and in turn stimulates
his extension technique parthenogenesis.
(Parthenogenesis) Kurourushi’s parthenogenesis
process, grants the curse spirit the ability to
produce even more cockroaches. On top of that the
cursed spirit can use this process to reproduce an
identical yet entirely new cursed spirit, however
in order to preserve the original cockroaches
existence, the cursed energy from the parent is
passed on to the child when it died as so on.
(Earthen Insect Trance) Last of the cockroaches
known techniques, Earthen Insect Trance allows the
cursed spirit to conjure up flying insects that
carry large sacs filled with a liquid substance
that gets released when destroyed. If the curse
spirits opponent gets to sloppy when taking one
out and the substance gets into the target's
eyes, it will start to impair their vision.
Smallpox Deity - Third out
of the known special grades,
Smallpox Deity is one of the stronger curses
inside of Kenjaku’s storage of cursed spirits.
(Gravestone Technique) Smallpox Deity's cursed
technique Gravestone begins when it traps
its target inside a cramped coffin. After the
target is caught, the curse takes its left fist
and lowers it into its right hand. This motion
drops a giant gravestone on top of the coffin,
dealing heavy damage and burying the coffin
underground. Once the gravestone is placed,
the disease curse begins to countdown
from three. If the count reaches one,
the target will be infected with smallpox and die.
Dagon - Fourth and first of the disaster
curses, Dagon is one of the main threats that
make their appearance during Shibuya.
If it wasn't for Toji showing up,
its likely that a few of the main group
could have died fighting this curse.
(Disaster Tides) Its technique Disaster
Tides allows the user to manifest high
volumes of water and control it using
their cursed energy. It can be used as
a water shield for close and mid-range, and
as a large, sweeping wave for long-range.
Its efficiency is dependent upon the cursed
energy of the user and for that reason,
can only be utilized to its full potential by
someone adept in cursed energy manipulation.
Hanami - Weakest out of the Disaster
Curses, but still special grade ranked,
Hanami is equipped with a range of abilities that
if not taken seriously will deal serious damage.
(Disaster Plants) Hanami’s innate technique,
Disaster Plants allows the user to form and
control a variety of cursed fauna. Its
abilities are normally initiated with
ones mind by activating the technique next to
the intended target or on the user themselves.
The plants created by this technique can
vary in size, shape and make up. Anything
from simple flowers to giant wooden roots are all
things possible to be formed. All of the plants
that make up Disaster Plants
are made from cursed energy,
meaning that all creations can be
constructed and deactivated instantly.
The technique also grants the user the
ability to absorb the life energy from
real plants. They can then take that
energy, turn it into a sort of flower
offering and finally convert it into
cursed energy that the user can then use.
(Roots) One of the main extension techniques,
Roots, can create large tree roots that emerge
from the ground at will. If Hanami decides
to limit the reach and numbers of roots made,
the overall power and speed of the other roots
will increase. Obviously this works both ways
and the user can also greatly expand
the number of roots and their range,
at the sacrifice of speed and destructive power.
(Wooden Ball) As the name says, Wooden
Ball allows Hanami to create a single
or multiple wooden balls from cursed
energy. These wooden balls will then
shoot out one or two sharp branch attacks
in an attempt to skewer their target. The
disaster curse is also able to use
these to suspend herself in midair.
(Cursed Bud) The cursed bud is an attack that
launches flowers buds that feed on the cursed
energy of whoever it attaches to. The more
techniques someone afflicted with a bud uses,
the deeper the buds roots will
extend into their bodies feeding
off more cursed energy. These is also
the option of spawning a large flower
that can shoot off a massive
barrage of these cursed buds.
(Flower Field) The last technique we saw Hanami
use, Flower Fields, as the name would suggest can
create a circle of flowers around their opponents
that distracts them with an effect that removes
their will to fight. Hanami was also able to
use this technique remotely, by launching a
long range projectile that the ability activated
off. The only downside to this ability is that
if its user is weakened then Flower Field wont
be as effective at removing the will to fight.
Jogo - Possibly the strongest out of the disaster
curses, Goatjo or Jogoat is equipped with a few
techniques that would put pretty much any
sorcerer apart from Gojo on the back foot.
(Disaster Flames) The curses innate
technique, Disaster Flames allows the
user to form and control both fire and
lava. The flames are immensely powerful,
capable of instantly killing non-sorcerers
and critically injuring sorcerers. These
flames are visible to non-sorcerers and
possess properties similar to real flames.
The technique also grants the user the ability
to telepathically create miniature volcanoes on
any surface. These volcanoes are capable of firing
powerful lava towards the user's intended target.
(Ember Insects) One of the first
techniques we saw a curse use in
the story, Ember Insects allows Jogo to
summon small flying insect-like curses
from the volcanic opening in his head.
These curses had a large stingers that
produced a loud noise upon impact before
detonating into a flaming explosion.
(Maximum Technique: Meteor) Jogo's Maximum
Technique, Meteor generates a gigantic flaming
meteor that the user is able to hurl at their
target. The meteors size probably depends entirely
on how much cursed energy the curse is willing
to put into the attack. If this attack lands,
the impact it causes is on a whole new
level in terms of destructive force in
Jujutsu kaisen. It without question will
destroy entire sections of a city and is
even strong enough to wound a 15 finger Sukuna.
Knowing what I know now about Sukuna though,
im questioning if he was just gassing Jogoat
up or not. Love to know your thoughts on it
below. Either way I think this is what
makes him the most potent disaster curse.
Mahito - Getting towards the end
of this video now and on the final
of the four Disaster Curses, we have
the maniacal maniac himself, Mahito.
(Idle Transfiguration) As you all probably know,
this dude was equipped with Idle Transfiguration,
one of the most broken abilities in shounen.
Imagine if he was good fr, dude could've
healed a hospital of kids. So Idle Transfiguration
allows the user to reshape the soul of themselves
or anyone they physically touch. The shape of
the body is dependent on the shape of the soul,
so if the soul is distorted they body will
also distort. Therefore, someone using Idle
Transfiguration can disfigure their target's body
into hellish creature by warping their soul's
shape with just a touch. This process creates
what are known as "Transfigured Humans" The
only way to block this technique is by being
physically built differently. Weak sorcerers
stand absolutely no chance and even grade 1
sorcerers will transfigure after a touch or 2.
(Soul Multiplicity) First of
Mahito's created techniques,
Soul Multiplicity which is kinda like a base
technique that others work off, combines two
or more souls using Idle Transfiguration. By
slamming these two souls together it creates
a reaction due to the un-natural course
of soul-fusion taking place. This here
as I mentioned allows the user to derive more
techniques that take advantage of the reaction.
(Body Repel) One of these extension techniques,
Body Repel takes advantage of Soul Multiplicity’s
reaction. By increasing the energy of
the souls associated with this effect,
the user can generate an overwhelming wave
of transfigured humans that burst forth.
(Polymorphic Soul Isomer) Again
utilizing Soul Multiplicity,
the user this time combines all of
his useless souls with weak rejection
to create one body. This body is
called a Polymorphic Soul Isomer.
A Polymorphic Soul Isomer is an attack based
transfiguration with extremely deadly force.
However, the trade-off for its crazy
strength is its lack of durability. A
Polymorphic Soul Isomer can be killed with
a single direct hit using cursed energy.
(Instant Spirit Body Of Distorted Killing) The
Instant Spirit Body of Distorted Killing is a
special self-transfiguration that morphs the
user into a much more powerful state. Due to
the nature of Idle Transfiguration
and its connection to the soul,
Instant Spirit Body of Distorted Killing can
only be achieved when the user realizes the
truest essence of their being. This technique
not only greatly alters the user's appearance,
but increases their abilities, granting them
incredible offensive and defensive prowess.
Cursed Naoya - Finally last on the list of every
cursed technique inside of Jujutsu Kaisen, we got
the 1 Vengeful Cursed Spirit who has an ability
that isn't a domain expansion, Cursed Naoya.
(Cursed Projection Sorcery)
As a vengeful cursed spirit
Naoya somehow managed to retained his
innate technique. During his short time
as a curse it was shown to be greatly
improved on by his cursed spirits body.
(Acceleration Mode) An extension technique
he created as a cursed spirit Acceleration
Mode allows a curse to bring in air through
the inlets they might have as they fly. One
can then use the thrusting pressure and
their own cursed energy to eject the air
out for an increased speed. This is a
very specific technique designed for
the vengeful Naoya and I doubt anyone else
would ever be able to do something similar.